le sentiment anti-français c'est un
sentiment qui dure depuis très longtemps
qui sept ans comme une pas comme une
mode mais comme une sorte de cancer sur
des raisons fantasmées la plupart du
temps sur des éléments propagande et
comme il n'y a pas de répondant comme on
dément pas comme on s'attaque pas cette
propagande on la prend pas au sérieux et
ben elle s'étend elle se développe
l'élément déclencheur a été dernier coup
d'État militaire il y a eu trois coups
d'État militaires successifs en deux ans
le dernier responsable de coup d'État a
fait appel pour sa sécurité à un groupe
de mercenaires russes la seule façon de
préserver son pouvoir sans risque c'est
d'être préservé par garde pretorienne
étrangère il y a des chefs d'État en
Afrique qui sont protégés par des
groupes militaires et travers c'est pas
les mercenaires c'est vraiment des
militaires par exemple il y a des
soldats israéliens qui protègent telle
ou tel chef d'État en Afrique évidemment
que les groupes Wagner et pilotés par
Moscou l'arrivée des soldats russes
c'est naturellement assise sur une
propagande antioxydante anti
impérialiste anti colonial évidemment
anti française